bonjour à tous nouveaux débats sur tv 78
radio sensations en vue des élections
municipales et le premier tour du 15
mars la ville chef lieu du département
versailles à huit candidats déclarés à
la date de cet enregistrement le
dimanche 23 février on reçoit quatre
nouveaux candidats pour ce débat des
candidats qui auront leur temps de
parole chronométrés
c'est aussi un tirage au sort qui a fixé
l'ordre pour la première prise de parole
et c'est monsieur boury jean-michel
brûlerie qui a été attirée le premier
pour ce débat tête de liste versailles
démocratie directe vous avez été investi
par l'upm l'union populaire républicaine
un parti fondé par françois cellino
ancien candidat à la présidentielle
c'est votre seconde expérience
électorale puisque vous étiez candidat
lors des élections législatives en 2010
7 dans la troisième circonscription des
yvelines vous aviez récolté moins de 1%
des suffrages à l'époque pourquoi les
électeurs versailles et doivent-ils vous
faire confiance et voter pour vous le 15
mars
parce que nous sommes le seul parti
politique prend d'engagement que tous
les candidats seront un casier
judiciaire vierge
le bulletin numéro 3 nous nous engageons
à impliquer les 30 propositions de
l'association anticorruption anticor et
puis ce qui est important c'est la mise
en place d'un référendum d'initiative
locale parce que dans le cadre des
réformes territoriales la commune
et dans le cadre d'une intercommunale
intercommunalités dans les départements
d'une région et toutes ces politiques
qui sont décidées sont en réalité décidé
sans le choix des électeurs renommant
yeux tête de liste vivre versailles
écologie citoyenne vous êtes consultant
un transition écologique investi dans la
vie locale c'est votre première campagne
électorale en tout cas en tant que
candidat pourquoi les versaillais
versaillaise doivent-ils voté pour vous
dans trois semaines
nous sommes une liste indépendante non
partisane écologique est en fait
d'habitants il ya des centaines
d'habitants qui depuis quelques années
se sont mis en mouvement ont commencé à
faire des actions très concrètes sans
attendre que la politique l'amérique
les artisans que les entreprises se sont
mis en action directement et on s'est
dit ben en fait cette élection
municipale c'est l'occasion de partager
et proposer ce qu'on vit déjà en fête
qui ça notre attention and francine tête
de liste ensemble vivons versailles vous
avez été investi par le comité local en
marche dans votre liste on note
notamment la présence de didier baichère
conseil municipal et député de la
première circonscription des yvelines
dont la vie vous êtes directrice
administrative et financière c'est votre
aussi première campagne en tant que
candidate
vous êtes soutenus notamment aussi par
le mouvement radical pourquoi les
électeurs doivent t'ils vous faire
confiance dans trois semaines
alors en tant que référente du comité
local de versailles en marche je suis
depuis plus de trois ans
régulièrement sur le terrain à l'ecoute
des versaillais et pour soutenir nos
élus nous savons que les versaillais ont
envie d'un nouvel élan et nous portons
un projet progressiste avec trois
priorités relever le défi de la
transition écologique développer la
confiance et la cohésion sociale et
ouvrir la ville aux initiatives à
l'entrepreneuriat et à l'international
avec comme principal objectif
défendre les commerces de proximité et
l'emploi notre liste est une liste de
rassemblement c'est à dire qu'elle est
là une bonne partie des groupes des
adhérents de la réplique en marge mais
aussi ludique
le modem lui d eux donc le mouvement
radical dont vous avez cité et à
l'enfant qui est un parti de jeunes et
un tiers de citoyens sans étiquette et
qui s'engagent je veux pour la plupart
pour la première fois et nous avons plus
de 25% de la liste qui a moins de 30 ans
donc c'est une liste jeune dynamique qui
a une incroyable agilité créativité et
énergie à mettre au service des
versaillais
enfin marc dias gamma tête de liste le
réveil démocratique et solidaire vous
êtes le président fondateur d'une
société qui agit dans le domaine de
l'immobilier cette campagne des
municipales constituent pour vous aussi
une première en tant que candidat vous
avez reçu le soutien du parti communiste
du parti socialiste et d'europe écologie
les verts
pourquoi les versets doivent-ils voté
pour vous le 15 mars parce que notre
monde change et notre monde change et on
le voit à chacune et chacun le voir dans
l'ensemble des éléments de son quotidien
et face à ce changement et notamment
celui de l'urgence climatique qui
devient un changement prégnant que
chacune et chacun peut vivre dans son
for intérieur et dont le quotidien est
bien nous avons d'autres enjeux à mettre
dans une municipalité et partions dans
une ville comme versailles d'autres
enjeux se présente est on ne peut plus
peut-être gérer la ville comme elle
était gérée et à 10 ou 15 ans voilà
merci pour ce premier tour de table
parfaite transition pour notre première
thématique l'environnement quelques
éléments de cadrage pour ce débat
versailles est là promet première ville
zéro phyto depuis 2009 ça avait débuté
en 2006 c'est aussi quatre fleurs
versailles seulement trois villes ont ce
label 87 hectares d'espacés verts et
selon des données publiques que
peut-être vous comptez stoehr et ses 120
km de voirie utilisable pour les vélos
renault en dieu on va commencer avec
vous pour la thématique environnement
qui vous est forcément cher
vous proposez une alimentation
différente vous avez notamment signé la
charte cantine sans plastique vous
souhaitez aussi la sobriété des
équipements municipaux rénovation des
bâtiments
en fait dans notre programme et il
s'appelle audace o'dea deux aces et la
troisième lettre ca pour alimentation et
je parle de ça parce qu'en fait en
termes d'environnement nous avons la
conviction qu est ce qui peut être
aujourd'hui de plus important pour un
maire qu'est ce qui peut être plus
important pour un maire que de porter
son attention sur l'alimentation de nos
enfants
comment se fait-il que aujourd'hui on
propose à nos enfants des produits qui
depuis la vie des pesticides des
fongicides qui sont dans la nourriture
comment ça se fait ça franchement ça me
rend triste
du coup vos propositions concrètes
est-ce que vous avez vu il ya des
grandes villes comme saint-etienne qui
est deux fois plus grande que versailles
qui fait ça déjà depuis plusieurs années
donc je me pose vraiment la question est
donc ça c'est pour nous vraiment une
priorité
vous avez aussi mentionné la sobriété
des équipements municipaux se dire que
vous voulez soutenir la rénovation des
bâtiments
la sobriété ça veut dire que en fait il
ya déjà plein d'équipement
sauf qu'ils sont utilisés que pour une
seule tâche je vais dire une chose
simple par exemple les écoles les écoles
vous pouvez utiliser que pour les élèves
et en même temps il s'occupait que 30 à
50% du temps alors qu'ils aient des
salles alors qu'ils aient des
réfectoires alors qu'elle gymnase et ça
ça pourrait utiliser à plein d'autres
occasions
donc je suis étonné de ça et dans
l'environnement aussi pour éviter la
pollution dans la ville il ya quelque
chose qui se fait dans plein de villes
touristiques en vain dans le monde en
france qui sont les parkings relais et
donc nous avons le projet d'installer
des parkings relais pour que les
touristes puissent installer à leicester
de la ville et puis revenir dans la
ville avec des bus électriques
c'est une chose très simple marc dias
gamma parmi vos propositions il ya deux
repas végétarien par semaine la mise en
place d'un plan de mobilité sur dix ans
et alors peut-être plus étonnant
végétalisée la place d'armes
celle qui se trouve devant le château
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
précisément la ville mais voilà cette
place
quelle est la place aujourd'hui
d'environnement dans la vie de chacune
et de chacun elle est importante c'est à
dire que tout le monde prend conscience
que notre planète présente une
problématique globalement et donc il
faut à l'échelle d'une municipalité se
tourner un peu plus vers les femmes et
des hommes et l'environnement plutôt que
se tourner vers les choses et certains
ont déjà repris je vais pas reprendre le
thème mais je pourrais parler du béton
on a beaucoup construit à versailles
mais est ce qu'on s'est occupée des
femmes et des hommes et de
l'environnement
pas vraiment en fait on avait utilisé
des vhu n'a pas réalisé mais on n'a pas
été sur un plan global nous la liste
notre liste a pour objectif de prendre
la de l'écologie dans sa globalité à la
fois dans sa dimension humaine c'est à
dire le bien vive et le bien-être pour
les habitants et puis sur la dimension
écologique pour aider à cette transition
écologique et tenir compte de tous ces
nouveaux éléments qui fabrique notre
monde jean michel boury vous proposer
une préservation d'une écologie à
citoyenne est ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer c'est ce que j'ai lu sur le
tract de l'upm sur internet que tout le
monde peut consulter
si vous n'êtes pas d'accord vous pouvez
développer vos propositions pour
l'environnement oui nous sommes pour
privilégier les circuits courts
les producteurs locaux mais le problème
c'est que on est
on rentre dans des réformes
territoriales avec une métropolisation
du dd métropolisation qui est en cours
on concentre les richesses les
populations et ses eaux
on est face à un fait une problématique
c'est que pour les projets du grand
paris
on est en train de réaliser de prendre
des terres agricoles
donc on est en train de prendre de la
surface agricole qui vivent pourrait
justement servir pour les circuits
courts
on est en train d'augmenter en fait les
problèmes de pollution et venir de
circulation des infrastructures qui vont
qu'ils vont pas forcément suivre des
services publics qui de toute façon ne
ne suivront pas parce que les politiques
ne sont pas pour augmenter
les services publics et leur donner plus
de moyens et face à ça je ne sais pas
comment comment les choses vont évoluer
mais on a le sentiment qu'on est face à
une impasse où on veut tout et l'occe au
contraire en même temps vous êtes pour
l'arrêt de ces projets est ce que vous
pensez qu'une mêlant que peu pesé
je suis plutôt pour ce que ce soit des
ses grands projets soient décidées par
les versaillais
mais il faut savoir que en réalité dans
le cadre l'interco les compétences du
maire sont transférés à l'interco donc
les versaillais sera sûrement le
président de versailles grand parc
oui il est oui il le sera mais le
problème c'est que on s'éloigne de
versailles et s'éloigne de plus en plus
des décisions démocratiques en france
sinon si je reprends aussi votre
campagne
votre proposition vos propositions sur
internet vous voulez notamment planté un
arbre par jour donc j'ai compté ça fait
2190 sur six ans tendre aussi vers le
zéro déchet et mettre en place un plan
climat air énergie territorial alors
relever le défi de la transition
écologique c'est clairement notre
première priorité
ça va se traduire par le fait que le
premier adjoint sera en charge de la
transition écologique et de l'urbanisme
nous souhaitons nous fixer une ambition
de la neutralité carbone à l'horizon
2040 avec des jalons pour y arriver et
une contractualisation d'un certain
nombre d'objectifs mesurables avec
l'ademe l'agencé de l'environnement et
de la maîtrise de l'énergie et un
certain nombre de mesures très concrètes
pour qui pour améliorer surtout impacté
la vie des habitants
à savoir mieux se loger mieux se nourrir
mieux se déplacer donc les mesures en
question
c'est par exemple
développer évidemment on vous l'avait
déjà dit économie circulaire les
magasins de recyclage c'est publier
régulièrement une cartographie des
passoires thermiques pour accompagner
les habitants dans leur la nécessité de
rénover leur habitation
les aider à rechercher des solutions de
financement ça peut être aussi créer un
système vélo et lutter contre la
discontinuité des pistes de manière à
faire que ce soit continu et travailler
aussi sur le lutter contre le vol des
vélos parce que lorsqu'on veut
développer la mobilité douce
il faut sécuriser
[Musique]
le vélo est on on parlera de la sécurité
en dans la suite de ce débat je me
permets de vous arrêter parce que sinon
vous allez prendre beaucoup d'avancé
marqué à dia c'est quand même question
pourquoi vous ne voulez pas mesurer la
pollution dans versailles
si c'est quelque chose d'important mais
ça c'est la position des vues pour
informer les citoyennes et les citoyens
juste prévu de mesurer la pollution j'ai
prévu une mesuré la qualité de l'air
notamment puisqu'on sait qu'à certains
endroits il y aura des risques de
dégradation donc oui j'ai vu ça c'est
tout à fait prévu marque dia ses gammes
à peut-être sur vos propositions à vos
puisque vous avez un peu de retard sur
ce plan de mobilité sur dix ans j'ai cru
comprendre que ce sera structurant est
ce que vous pouvez nous en parler leur
parler parler notamment des mobilités
douces on a on a proposé de manière
concrète à tous les versets à versailles
et de réduire la vitesse des véhicules
est passé aux 30 km heure permanence
surtout versailles pourquoi d'abord
c'est un enjeu de sécurité pour les
citoyens et citoyennes et ça c'est
important
et puis ensuite c'est un enjeu de
diminution des rejets se donner de
pollution et versailles à 30 km h ça ne
pose aucun problème
c'est une ville qui est très dense et
j'aurais dit c'est l'objectif
tout à fait alors comment on va le faire
c'est ça qui est important finalement on
pourrait l'imposer
le maire pourrait l'imposer avec son
équipe municipale dire versailles sec 30
km ce serait là une erreur démocratique
on ne va pas chercher à imposer des
choses on va et on va en parler plus
tard dans le débat nous allons proposer
l'élection de mr de quartier et ce sont
les conseils de quartier les maires de
quartier et les citoyens qui doivent
décider de l'application d'une politique
ou pas il ya certaines rues où il faudra
le faire de manière globale nous nous
privilégions le fait de passer à 30
kilomètres dans la ville mais il faudra
consulter les femmes et des hommes de
versailles justement nouvelle parfaite
transition je sais pas si vous le faites
exprès pour la démocratie locale 86
mille habitants à versailles est ce que
il comment rapprocher le citoyen des
politiques c'est un sujet devenu majeur
dans les campagnes récentes politiques
vos propositions sur ce sujet en france
simon si on pouvait commencer par vous
sachant que vous avez du temps d'avant
ce donc voilà juste pour vous le sachiez
pour la suite du débat
d'aversa une ville résolument tourné
vers les citoyens et qu'ils misent sur
les acteurs notamment nous voulons
redonner une nouvelle dimension au
conseil de quartier en les rendant plus
visibles des citoyens parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de citoyens qui ne savent même
pas que ça existe en publiant par
exemple régulièrement un calendrier des
réunions on en ouvrant les conseils de
quartier sur les associations ou des
acteurs locaux en organisant des
ateliers thématiques une boîte à idées
enfin on a pas mal de propositions sur
le sujet on souhaite aussi rajouter des
instances consultatives qui fait pour
fédérer les initiatives donc on a pensé
à un comité citoyen d'innovation de
développement qui serait composé de
versailles et tirés au sort avec un
budget pour encourager les projets
citoyens
un comité des associations aussi pour
fédérer leurs actions sur l'ensemble de
la ville un conseil municipal des jeunes
un conseil municipal des enfants voilà
où je voudrais ajouter un dernier point
allez-y nous allons nous engageons nous
aussi à travers la charte transparancy
international à respecter les six
propositions pour renforcer l'intégrité
la transparence de la vie publique
locale dont deux mesures principales
seraient moins de temps pour la suite
mais les aggravent la transparence des
indemnités perçues par les élus et la
lisibilité des documents administratifs
et financiers
renouant dieu vous aussi vous avez signé
enfin vous avez signé nos charts et
celle de l'impact pour du pacte pour la
transition élaboré par une soixantaine
d'organisations qui composent qui
propose notamment la co construction des
politiques locales
est ce que ça veut dire qu' aucune
décision ne sera prise sans l'accord des
citoyens en fait c'est un sujet
intéressant parce que la question c'est
j'adore en fait tout le fait qu'on ce
qu'on partage là en ce moment parce
qu'on a l'impression qu'on est quasiment
d'accord sur beaucoup de choses
la question peut être c'est peut-être qu
est-ce que comme on le vit déjà dans les
cinquante trois colistiers colistière de
notre liste ça fait six ans qu'on fait
déjà d'écologie qu'on roule en vélo
qu'on fait des jardins potagers qu'on
fait du compost qu'on est déjà actif
dans la vie publique personnellement sur
le quartier de port fontaine
dans le conseil de quartier de la
mandature actuelle j'ai mis en oeuvre la
zone 30 complète sur le quartier de parc
fontaine donc et déjà des choses
possibles et en fait c'est comment on ne
choisit de le vivre aujourd'hui et on a
une mesure peut-être un peu phare qui
est les budgets participatifs
il ya aujourd'hui la possibilité nous on
a prévu notre programme 2,8 millions ca
présente 7% c'est pas énorme du budget
d'investissement de la ville dans des
budgets participatifs qui seront choisis
qui seront identifiés qui seront
évidemment évaluer par les services
techniques et qui seront votées par les
habitants alors oui les élus ont un sens
ils ont une fonction et en même temps
c'est comment on peut travailler avec
les élus et les services techniques et
c'est ce qu'on fait déjà dans notre
liste chez nos colistiers depuis
quelques années marque dia ce gamin sur
cette question de la démocratie locale
vous parliez d'élections au suffrage des
maires de quartier eux aussi dotés d'un
budget personnalisé
alors c'est créer la démocratie pourquoi
face à tout ce qu'on a aimé prendre
cette urgence climatique ce nécessaire
transition que chacune et chacun
comprend il faut d'abord adapter la
gouvernance d'une villa ça est ce que
vous imaginez aujourd'hui qu'un maire
d'une ville de presque 100 mille
habitants peut prendre toutes les
décisions qui vont impacter l'écologie
de chacune et de chacun au quotidien non
c'est aux citoyennes et aux citoyens de
construire leur propre projet politique
là-dessus leur propre projet de
l'environnement c'est c'est à eux de
faire leur tour c'est pas du haut vers
le bas que ce fait que se font les
choses c'est du bas vers le haut les
informations doivent remonter au maire
d'une ville mais pour ça il faut que
dans chaque quartier
il est des femmes et des hommes
impliqués et c'est pour ça que nous
proposons et nous souhaitons l'élection
des maires de quartier au suffrage
universel par les représentants du
quartier
voilà donc des conseils de quartier
complètement avec une nouvelle
démocratie politique celle de l'élection
qui ont la légitimité d'avoir reçu
d'élections politiques et comme d'autres
retours de ces tables vous est favorable
à l'organisation de référendums de
quartier sur quelles questions tout peut
tout type de questions ou type de projet
repartiront un collectif de 500 citoyens
veut porter un projet eh bien il
pourrait en référé à son maire de
quartier élus et le maire le maire de
quartier on parlera
le maire de la ville va organiser
régulièrement tous les mois son conseil
des maires sur lequel seront seront
reportés tous les projets qui auront une
citoyens mais avec un vote référendaire
effectivement sur un collectif de 500
citoyens qui veulent porter un projet
alors ce projet pourra s'imposer à la
mairie tout à fait et j'ai en michel
boury c'est un sujet justement qui vous
est très cher le référendum vous voulez
mettre en oeuvre le référendum
d'initiative locale le riz l'huile le
riz le référendum à zurich
on a beaucoup entendu parler avec les
jets les zones déjà la mise en place du
référendum
tout simplement parce que lorsque
lorsqu'on démarre de grand projet ou
l'intention de mettre en place des
grands projets comme le palais le projet
de plateau de satory ou du grand saclay
où la caserne pion aux enfin il a
énormément sur versailles c'est qu'ils
vont engager beaucoup d'investissement
il faudrait aussi demander à la
population si elle est d'accord ou pas
ou versailles et oui effectivement de
vous remettre un pass le référendum
d'initiative locale qui permet à tout
citoyen de formuler une question de la
déposer en mairie
et puis une fois que le nombre de
signatures est obtenue au passage on
passe par le référendum et la mairie
appliquera la décision qui sera prise
par les versaillais
mais il faut pas oublier que versailles
n'est pas une commune complètement isolé
dans la france elle dépend aussi d'une
interco avec les transferts de
compétences un demi-verre l'interco donc
une perte de notre démocratie
et les choses ne pourront se faire que
dans la mesure du possible c'est à dire
qu'il ya des contraintes par exemple on
doit
le comment ça s'appelle le laisse dire
je me souviens plus j'ai un trou c'est
pas grave
le schéma directeur de la région ile de
france 2 oui oui qui prévoient qu'ils
demandent une augmentation de
l'urbanisation de 10 à 15% et les la
commune de versailles étaient obligés
d'inscrire sa son pays et l'ue en tout
c'est toutes ces questions en fait de
deux changements de la politique du
territoire
elle ne passe jamais par par la
recherche d'épaves jamais par une
démocratie locale
ça se fait entre élus et nous on
souhaiterait justement remettent les
versaillais dans un processus
démocratique et qu'il soit à l'origine
de grandes décisions parce que tous ces
projets vont quand même avoir une grande
incidence et vont voir vont se
confronter frontalement avec tous les
besoins d'écologie d'urgence et
écologique etc
on va aller des grands projets dans la
deuxième partie de ce débat fera pouvoir
que vous nous rejoignez pratiquement si
effectivement locales et on est obligé
de passer aujourd'hui un oui mais quand
vous allez faire pour revendre mettre en
place des solidarités humaines
assomption 2003 le maire des quartiers
mai
on va mettre le 15 et à faire du
lobbying pas du tout les maires de
quartier le suffrage universel par les
citoyennes et souviens d'un quartier
c'est indispensable pour mettre en
oeuvre ce serait bien de passer de
passer par les maisons de quartier mais
nous on fait encore plus simple bazire a
directement par la mairie on s'adressera
aux versets renault en dieu peut-être
vous avez du retard sur cette question
du référendum est ce que c'est un projet
aussi vous vous portez vous demandez
l'avis directement sur des projets très
locaux aux habitants la question c'est
comment on fait et comme on le fait déjà
je veux dire faire des plans sur la
planète en disant on va faire comme ça
aujourd'hui comment ça se passe je dis
qu'aujourd'hui dans nos structures de
notre liste dans nos associations
nous avons déjà ses modes de gouvernance
partagée ans expérimente on s'entraîne
on prépare ça on va pas changer tout
d'un coup les façons de faire
quand les habitudes qu'on les habitants
qu'ont les politiques ont les élus qu'on
les services techniques ça va pas se
transformer comme ça c'est pas il suffit
pas de dire ou à faire de la
participation du collectif cetera c'est
plus compliqué que ça dans notre vécu
c'est déjà transformé notre posture
notre position et déjà on le vit nous
est donc comment on transforme ça si
c'est si compliqué si loin est-ce que
vous avez être même des pistes de
réflexion et d'actions cédées
c'est toujours ça fait six ans qu'on est
dans l'urgence donc voilà on y est on le
vit ont déjà transformé c'est déjà
commencer par nous cela se transforme et
nous sait déjà comment est-ce qu'on va
accueillir l'autre comment accueillir
l'opposant comment avec liant le
marginal
comment va cueillir le rebelle parce que
toutes ces personnes là elle nous parle
de nous elle nous parle comment on veut
fonctionner aussi je vous je vous
proposera six jours si ça vous convient
on arrive à la moitié de ce débat de
passer à un autre sujet une autre
thématique l'attractivité du territoire
et ses grands projets dont vous parliez
le château de versailles pour rappeler
quelques chiffres c'est tout de même 8
millions de touristes par an qui
viennent à versailles il ya les jo de
2024 qui arrive aussi avec à versailles
avec l'accueil des épreuves d'équitation
le grand paris l'arrivée de la ligne 18
prévus normalement en 2030 et puis il ya
aussi dans ce grand parent et le sujet
de la fusion entre le département des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine porté par
les deux présidents des départements est
ce que vous êtes pour ou contre libre à
vous de vous positionner
je voulais vous entendre sur ce sujet
marc dias gamma vous avez un peu de
retard dont vous avez le temps de
développer vos positions là dessus alors
sur les géo effectivement toutes les
parties épreuves d'équitation mais je
note qu'elles vont avoir lieu dans le
parc du château derrière grand canal
donc ça va pas tu n'es pas la propriété
je n'ai pas la mériter de la mairie donc
ça va avoir un impact peut-être un peu
plus fait on peut estimer sur versailles
mais c'est important la question c'est
combien de touristes vont revenir sur
versailles dans cette épreuve
on n'a pas encore des dépréciations mais
il va falloir même faire une étude
je pense que les études d'impact
l'ingénierie permet de faire des études
d'impact de manière claire ce qui n'a
pas encore été fait par la mairie
actuelle et pourtant les jo de 2024
cette chose d'important on peut
s'étonner que la mairie actuelle n'est
pas fait encore d'études d'impact sur
les retombées économiques et les
retombées sociales et comment en
profiter un maximum du coup selon vous
comment anticiper pour par exemple que
les touristes visitent certains
quartiers de versailles et fassent vivre
les commerces de proximité
alors déjà il faut la prendre la chose
c'est que les épreuves se passe bien et
que se déroule bien
c'est à dire qu'une grande ville 2024
est important c'est un enjeu important
donc il faut que les infrastructures
soient soient prêtes savez des
infrastructures as éphémère en fait
puisque elles vont démonter après donc
des coûts économiques élevés pour la
ville et il faut d'abord mesurer
l'impact économique le gain potentiel
que pourrait avoir la vie de l'assuré je
voulais quand même revenir sur un point
que j'ai relevées dans votre programme
pour le commerce de proximité c'est la
gratuité des parkings privés enfin vous
souhaitez un négocier la gratuité des
parkings privés pour la première heure
pour renforcer l'activité commerciale
tout à fait pour pour inciter à une plus
grande mobilité et renforçaient qui mais
nous parlons tout à l'heure d'un autre
sujet aussi pour renforcer
l'attractivité de la ville sur le plan
des affaires et de l'économie
j'espère que nous évoquons sujet qui est
très important l'attractivité du
territoire en france simon vos
propositions principales vous souhaitez
notamment ont parlé des jeux olympiques
de 2024 vous parlez vous aussi de la
coupe du monde de rugby
2023 vous voulez une nouvelle offre
touristique pour versailles est ce que
vous pouvez détailler sa plus ou moins
tout de même rapidement
oui alors nous souhaitons faire des
jo-2000 24 et aussi de la coupe du rugby
une occasion de 2
porter un projet fédérateur et qui
démarre dès maintenant c'est à dire
qu'on a appelés vers vers 20 24
l'objectif étant de de faire bouger les
versailles et parce qu'on sait que il ya
près d'un français sur deux qui déclare
ne pas pratiquer régulièrement du sport
dont 60% des femmes et le sport adapté
au cir est d'ailleurs difficile d'accès
donc à nos axes c'est de développer la
pratique sportive et physique des jeunes
notamment et donc nous avons tout un
programme autour de cet objectif fédérer
les quartiers avec des un certain nombre
d'événements vers les légions 2024 on va
donner la parole à jean michel boire et
vous pourrez rebondir ensuite sur sur
vos propositions sur ces grands projets
alors j'ai déjà cru comprendre que vous
n'étiez pas favorable à ces projets vous
voulez porter une défense vigilante des
commerces et artisanats locaux oui c'est
à dire je suis pas favorable aux grands
projets non je je je je dis que ça ils
vont poser de gros problèmes à venir
c'est à dire que nous on est en train de
préparer des problèmes intérieurs
vraiment avoir du coup oui non mais je
dis que c'est pas moi de décider tout
seul c'est c'est la population décidée
s'est ouverte à être décidée et donc la
question c'était c'est vos projets pour
l'attractivité du territoire et j'ai
noté une mesure défense vigilante enfin
si c'est une mesure dépenses vigilant
des commerces et artisanats locaux je
vous demandais comment
oui va déjà nous faut mettre en place 30
minutes
de stationnement gratuites mais pour
l'épauler commerces locaux
oui c'est sûr le problème des commerces
et qu'il ya de grands centres
commerciaux et effectivement il faut on
va on va continuer la politique et qui
est appliquée pour protéger le pour
protéger les commerçants oui mais une
seule façon c'est un combat oui tout à
fait renault en dieu vous vous parlez du
développement de la monnaie locale la
racine alors je cette monnaie locale a
été créée dans la vallée de chevreuse à
l'automne 2010 8
comment vous souhaitez diffuser cette
monnaie locale en fait elles
fonctionnent déjà à versailles a
commencé oui récemment à se diffuser
ça fait un an que des commerçants qui
commencent à l'utiliser et des habitants
donc l'idée de la mode locale ça permet
en fait de faciliter les échanges et ça
accélère les échanges locaux
ces salles intentions après en terme
d'attractivité j'ai la croyance que
effectivement par les touristes qui
viennent à versailles et j'aime bien
l'idée de libérer la place d'armes des
voitures avec les parkings relais à
l'extérieur comme on en a parlé
qu'est ce qu'on fait on peut faire des
jardins sur la plaza ça me plaît bien
j'aime l'idée est aussi de faire des
locations de vélos pourquoi parce que ça
va permettre aux touristes de voir des
avec des pistes cyclables vont pouvoir
se promener dans versailles parce que si
vous marchez ça fait un peu loin
versailles est donc en vélo ça permet
circuler et ça permet d'aller chez les
commerçants ça permet d'aller vite se
promener d'aller voir d'autres éléments
de versailles donc ça c'est un élément
d'attractivité et c'est pas un coup
ponctuelle on va faire un one shot ou
infra des installations à être beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup d'argent pour réussir
l'opération
pour moi c'est pas ça que j'ai envie de
vivre dans ma vie du local et puis j'ai
aussi envie de vivre à aider des voix
des habitants qui vont faciliter leurs
déplacements
alors ceux qui le peuvent parce que
certains ne peuvent pas et satin
effectivement sont contraints de prendre
la voiture et ça je suis vraiment
tranquille avec ça et un temps je me dis
qu'il ya plein déplacement parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas très sûr qui
pourrait se faire à vélo et qui qu'on
peut faciliter et donc l'attractivité
sait aussi comment on facilite les
échanges localement et par exemple
comment on permet à des jeunes couples
de pouvoir s'installer à versailles
parce qu'en termes d'attractivité
si on parle du mobilier je pense que
c'est ok et tout le monde est ok là
dessus que ya une certaine attractivité
de versailles vue prix l'immobilier est
ce que c'est ça qu'on veut continuer
est-ce qu'on veut devenir le marais est
ce qu'on veut devenir une ville superbe
de personnes extrêmement riche et et
et plutôt âgés ou est-ce qu'on veut être
autre chose et comment est ce qu'on va
faire cette activité attractivité avec
des jeunes
on a encore pas mal de temps dans ce
débat j'aurais peut-être entendre votre
position sur un projet qui va structurer
l'avenir de versailles c'est la
métropole du grand paris alors les
décisions ont été arrêtées pour le
moment versailles et en dehors de cette
métropole elle le sera peut-être à
l'avenir et ce sujet à des conséquences
déjà directement puisque les
départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine en tout cas leur
président souhaite fusionner j'aimerais
avoir votre position là-dessus ce que
vous êtes favorable à la métropole du
grand paris est ce qu'elle doit englober
versailles est ce qu'il faut que les
deux départements fusionnent jean-michel
le but est là dessus oui c'est une
position est très claire c'est comme les
fusions de communes
c'est c'est ce que c'est ça doit passer
par référendum à doivent pas être forcés
donc pour les départements c'est
exactement la même chose on doit passer
par la voie référendaire
alors les présidents disent qu'ils ont
la majorité donc élus par les électeurs
et que que du coup leur projet et
démocratique
oui bien sûr bien sûr mais le monde et
moqueries sidéré je relaie les
informations c'est bien malgré sa rolls
c'est à dire non démocratie directe tout
tout tout se fait entre élus et s'est
passé quand même ce sont des projets qui
vont qui vont avoir des conséquences de
multiples niveaux aussi bien de
concentration de population de
concentration de richesses et tout ça au
détriment de la france périphérique et
vous est ce que vous avez peut-être en
tant que éventuel futur maire de
versailles une idée quand même de ce que
vous souhaitez pour pour l'avenir et ces
sujets là précisément je sais c'est en
réalité c'est tout le problème et qui se
passe
en ile de france c'est à dire qu'on
assiste à un bétonnage avec des dés de
nouvelles lignes ou des lignes qu
rallonge qu'on va qu'on va bétonner
bétonné et je sais pas comment vous dire
ça mais je pense que c'est c'est aux
citoyens de décider
alors on peut on peut avoir il faut il
faut évoluer les métropoles en fait les
métropoles se sont se sont sont dans un
cadre de mondialisation de compétitivité
mais ce sont des politiques qui sont
imposés en fait par notre part notre
appartenance à l'union européenne ce a
été décidé en haut lieu s'est passé par
sarkozy en 2007 je coince est passé par
la loisne
organisé par la loi notre et donald a
fait longtemps qu'on en parle oui c'est
sûr c'est que la ligne 18 arrivera en
2030 à versailles oui oui c'est fait le
oui en france si mon opposition sur ces
sujets qui sont malgré tout très
structurants pour l'avenir de la ville
nous notre objectif c'est clairement ce
sera de défendre les versailles et les
intérêts des versaillais
il est clair que ce dont deux hors
métropole est clair que si la métropole
du grand paris s'arrête à la au
département de la première couronne
nous risquons de d'y perdre en
attractivité et nous sommes plutôt du
coup favorable à un rapprochement
néanmoins on pense que la région et des
agglos pourrait être suffisant pour
réduire le millefeuille administratif et
que
une comme une question à se poser
surtout tout cet empilage de niveau est
à notre avis ça ne mérite une large
concertation clairement parce que les
enjeux sont considérables en tout cas
pour l'attractivité il est nécessaire
que versailles fasse entendre sa voix et
pèse dans le débat pour défendre nos
intérêts mahdia ce gamin sur ce sujet
oui j'ai peut-être un peu différemment
parce qu'en fait vous parlez de
l'attractivité d'une ville
mais c'est quoi l'attractivité d'une
ville c'est le bonheur de ses citoyens
c'est le bien être et le bien vivre
qu'elle a vu leur sang donc ce qui rend
une ville attractive aujourd'hui c'est
le fait qu'on y vive bien qu'on ait le
sentiment bien vivre voilà pourquoi ce
qu'on peut entendre bien dans la
métropole du grand paris à verser oui si
on renversa il ya encore des atouts
d'attractivité en réserve améliorer le
bien vivre un des citoyens améliorer le
bien-être de chacune et chacun dans son
versailles quotidien et puis on parlait
tout à l'heure des aspects économiques
et puis on a déjà parlé de l'aspect de
la transition écologique et c'est
important et c'est ça qui renforce
si aujourd'hui c'est demain versailles
est une ville où la transition
écologique a été mis en place où il ya
un mieux vivre où il ya un mieux être
alors elle sera une ville très
attractive et comment voulez vous
percevez ça aujourd'hui sur ces
questions là je pense que de grands il
ya des groupes de grands facteurs
d'amélioration
on est peut-être tout tout au début
d'une démarche il faut mettre en oeuvre
cette démarche
d'où d'ailleurs changer le vote
démocratique pour pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre cette démarche mais pour rendre
versailles attractif
rendons la une ville de bien-être et de
bienvenue un renault en lieu sûr sur ces
sujets je suis d'accord avec monsieur
oui c'est à dire si vous pouviez
développer parce que sinon on va finir
plus tôt cette édition ouais en fait
mais ça veut dire quoi te concentrer il
ya des zones en france qui sont désertes
où il ya des villages qui sont qui se
désertifient on est vide et on concentre
sur la métropole aussi avec le grand
paris express c'est de justement de
désenclaver par exemple paris et la
petite couronne
c'est pas mal non je je
c'est pascal et c'est de concentrer
comme ça que c'est souvent représenté la
concentration économique va favoriser
l'économie au service de quoi de
l'économie ou des habitants d'une
mondialisation d'une compétition
internationale de grandes métropoles et
tout ça ça découle en fait de politiques
européennes où on doit on doit la france
en fait doivent être organisées
différemment c'est à dire il va rester
des grande interco de grandes régions
est une structure supranationale les
communes les départements doivent
disparaître et l'état on va passer au
dernier à la dernière grande thématique
de cette émission la sécurité alors à
versailles il y à 24 agents municipaux
qui sont armés depuis 2010 cette équipe
et aussi de caméras piétons depuis
récemment depuis 2001 19 il y à 121 une
caméra de vidéosurveillance qui sont
installés dans la ville
vos positions sur ce sujet une nouvelle
fois renault en lieu sûr sur la sécurité
qu'est ce que vous proposez
mais quand j'entends sécurité moi
j'entends dignité humaine
j'entends qu'elle est ma sécurité
physique et ce que nous proposons c'est
un centre médical de santé avec des
médecins qui sont payés par la commune
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui à
versailles si vous trouvez vous les
cherchez un médecin généraliste venait
d'arriver
vous allez pas en trouver si vous avez
une urgence un week-end ou savez quelque
chose un pic maladie en week-end ou en
soirée
ben vous allez hôpital mignot qui n'a
pas fait l'expérience d'heure d'attenté
aux urgences de mignot et donc je
m'interroge vraiment là dessus et j'ai
consulté des médecins sur versailles et
ils m'ont dit bah en fait je me suis
rendu compte qu'il existait en fait des
centres médicaux de santé il ya des
médecins qui seraient ravis des parties
vais parce qu'ils font du temps partiel
parce qu'ils veulent s'occuper des
enfants et donc entre eux par la
sécurité moi j'ai envie de parler la
sécurité d'abord physique personnel et
si j'ai envie de me soigner comment ça
se passe est-ce que je vais attendre
quelques heures à minuit
non donc c'est la proposition mcdyess
gamme assure sur la sécurité quelle est
votre position à vous aussi peut-être
une position
un peu leurs différentes la sécurité
pour moi pour l'équipe avec lequel on a
travaillé ensemble sur tous ces aspects
là c'est le bien-être est bien vivre
parce qu'une ville plus sûre
c'est une ville où il fait bon vivre et
s'il fait beau vivre la ville est déjà
plus sûres et puis quand vous parlez de
sécurité parler de sécurité physique le
comprendre mais avez vous parlé de
sécurité alimentaire par exemple il ya
plusieurs formes de sécurité voilà
est-ce que à nos enfants aujourd'hui à
versailles a plus de chance d'animer sa
santé avec une alimentation pas saine ou
est-ce qu'il a plus de chance d'habiter
sa santé par la négation physique
absolument faire sags versailles
versailles est une ville très saine ça
il faut aujourd'hui comme on dit donc je
pense que la sécurité alimentaire me
paraît beaucoup plus importante que la
sécurité physique alors un franc ciment
vous partagez pas forcément ce point de
vue vous constaté une augmentation de la
délinquance averse est alors comment
lutter corps nous avons eu des faits
divers récents qu'il confirme ainsi que
les cambriolages avec séquestration donc
non il ya quand même des événements
versa qui montre qu'il ya des choses à
faire dans le domaine
nous nous proposons d'augmenter le
nombre de policiers municipaux de
renforcer aussi d'avoir des agents des
mesures de médiateur dans les quartiers
nous proposons aussi des actions de
sensibilisation des citoyens contre le
harcèlement
parce qu'il ya la sécurité est vraiment
des agressions mais il ya aussi des
problématiques dans l'est dans les
collèges lycées et autres la formation
aux gestes de premiers secours qui est
un moyen aussi de renforcer la sécurité
nous nous allons créer un poste de
référent aux violences faites aux femmes
et aux enfants et des actions de
sensibilisation entre en faveur de
l'égalité femmes hommes
et puis renforcé le dispositif voisins
vigilants et solidaires
tiens à préciser pour pour contribuer à
renforcer le sentiment de confiance
jean michel boury pour conclure sur
cette thématique delà de la sécurité
vous n'avez pas encore pris la parole
mais quasiment le même temps de parole
que les autres donc libre à vous de
discuter là dessus mais vous aurez moins
de temps pour conclure éventuellement
oui bon c'est un problème général
national
ici
je suis plus à défendre le service
public c'est à dire que c'est la police
nationale gendarmerie d'assurer la
sécurité sur le territoire
la baisse des dotations globales de
fonctionnement de l'état vont cesser une
perte de moyens financiers pour la
municipalité pour parler des forces de
polices municipales ou autres donc on
est tout on est dans un contexte qui
fait qui va faire que les en fait c'est
difficile de régler ce problème qu'ils
appellent un mot nationale qui est dû à
une monnaie trop forte pour la france a
une une dégradation de l'industrie
française et c'est l'appauvrissement de
la population mondiale vous souhaitiez
alors qu'on fasse à la conclusion livre
tout à fait son la sécurité de la
sécurité c'est une affaire aussi de
chacune et de chacun des citoyens
et quand on n'a pas assez démocratie
locale et bien les citoyennes et
citoyens mais effectueront n'a pas
d'autre choix que de mettre des
policiers mais à la place de mettre des
policiers ou de renforcer même si ça
peut être utile dans certains endroits
fera peut-être laissé un peu plus la
main ou versaillaise aux versaillais
si on renforce la responsabilité des
conseils de quartiers à travers
l'élection des maires de quartier on
reste construit l'église sera d'autant
plus les femmes et des hommes apprennent
ce coin de leur entourage à prendre soin
de leur entourage
c'est ça le bien vivre et le bien être
on va conclure ce débat avec vos temps
de parole justement deux conclusions
parole libre vous êtes tout à fait libre
de parler du sujet que vous souhaitez
revenir sur un point du débat ne pas
interpeller en revanche un autre
candidat parce que ce sera à chacun
votre dernier temps de parole vous aurez
tous à peu près deux minutes certains 2
minutes 30 c'est votre cas renault en
dieu pour pour conclure ce débat qui est
diffusée je rappelle son tv 78 et radio
sensations on prend l'ordre inverse du
tour d'introduction donc vous commencez
marque dias da gama vous avez deux
minutes précisément pour pour conclure
parmi les nombreux éléments de preuve le
bien vivre le bien-être le
renouvellement démocratique il y en a un
autre dont nous n'avons pas encore parlé
qui est très important c'est je vais le
déclin en deux thèmes c'est un petit peu
ce que peut apporter une mairie
aujourd'hui à ses citoyennes et citoyens
pas uniquement s'occuper des
infrastructures mais s'occupait des
femmes et des
mais ne pas s'occuper que des choses
mais s'occuper des femmes et des hommes
la création notamment d'un prix
d'innovation le prix soleil qui va
permettre de récompenser une équipe de
jeunes versaillaise ou versaillais qui
présente un projet de halle est
récompensé par un lot de 15000 25000 ou
cinquante mille euros bas puis pour
qu'ils puissent monter leur boîte et
leur start up dans versailles
sarr enfoncera l'économie versaillaise
et ça permettra de dynamiser
il ya beaucoup de prix sur l'innovation
des prix d'excellence versailles ville
soleil doit avoir elle aussi son prix
d'excellence une deuxième chose que la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments des
logements privés
nous proposons la mise en oeuvre des
nouveaux radiateurs numérique plutôt
qu'utiliser nos radiateurs nos vieux
appareils de chauffage
les radiateurs numériques sont des
radiateurs qui chauffe mais qui choque
parce qu'on fait du calcul avec il ya
des microprocesseurs de danse a fait du
calcul est davantage par exemple les
créateurs comme le tue h1 c'est que la
facture de chauffage est payé par le
fournisseur qui vous installe l'appareil
numérique de chauffage donc c'est aussi
une solidarité humaine
ça peut permettre de diminuer la facture
énergétique de celles et ceux qui ont le
moins de moyens mais surtout c'est une
nouvelle manière aussi de prendre soin
de la nature est encore une fois dans le
cadre de la transition écologique
ces nouveaux radiateurs numérique en
france sinon vous avez deux minutes 2
minutes 10 pour conclure bien notre
ambition c'est de faire de versailles
une ville attractive et rayonnante
protectrice et inclusive résolument
ancré dans le 21e siècle notre projet
est mis en ligne sur un site ensemble
vivons versailles point fr sur lequel
vous pouvez trouver là des fiches de
présentation de tous nos colistiers une
boîte à idées
les dates de nos prochaines réunions
publiques la prochaine des d'ailleurs
lieu mercredi
et comme surtout comment nous contacter
donc moi je dis rendez vous le 15 mars
pour donner un nouvel élan à versailles
je suis prête
mon équipe est prête pour être en
responsabilité
renault en dieu 2 minutes 30 pour
conclure ce débat pour vous ça fait
plusieurs années que nous sommes en
actions que nous avons réalisé des
centaines de projets
et en fait on va continuer après y'a pas
besoin forcément d'élus pour ça
l'écologie on l'a vu déjà la colo j on
est déjà en action dedans après on a
plaisir à le partager
c'était notre intention en étant présent
dans cette campagne
notre liste s'appelle vivre versailles
point org
en fait on aime plus peut-être écouté
que convaincre et j'aime l'idée que dans
la trentaine d'actions qu'on a fait dans
les trois mois de sept campagnes passées
et à venir
on est dans des espaces d'écouté nous
sommes dans des possibilités de pouvoir
échanger partager comme ce soir par
exemple c'était vraiment agréable
j'ai apprécié ça m'a permis de
rencontrer des gens que je ne sais pas
avec qui je vois que je suis en lien et
peut-être j'espère qu'on va être amenés
à se rencontrer plus tard jean michel
boeri vous concluez ce débat et vous
avez une minute 40 jusqu'à une minute je
remettrai ces élections dans le cas pas
d'enjeu
nationale c'est à dire que les maires et
conseillers municipaux vont permettre d
ce sont les grands électeurs qui vont
les sénateurs les sénateurs qui auront
le pouvoir
de lancer la procédure de destitution du
président de la république
ils auront aussi la possibilité
rassemblant lors du congrès de
versailles rassemblement des deux
assemblées de modifier la constitution
et le maire lui et enfin la possibilité
comme d'autres élus de parrainer le
président de république
je remettais juste les enjeux de ces
élections municipales et ce sera votre
conclusion ces élections municipales le
premier temps je le rappelle le 15 mars
prochain merci à vous quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat on voit vos temps
de parole s'afficher à peu près égaux
merci d'avoir vous aussi joué le jeu je
rappelle que vous serez opposés
notamment dans cette campagne municipale
à françois de mazières le maire sortant
à jack ma arnaud mercier et fabien
bouglé vous pouvez retrouver ces débats
sur les élections municipales à
versailles sur notre site internet en
replay les écouter aussi sûr sensation
yvelines et la campagne des élections
municipales se poursuit sur tv soixante
dix huit merci à tous
[Musique]